>> I QUOTE, UNQUOTE,
HAVE
RECRUITS, AND THEY ARE REVEALIW
, ONBIE , LL PAD
MTAK ITD  O,
EAR to TO
OR
N  C.BEESKWIER THAINSSSI PATES
B
IN KINIR'SBAYEE S E DE TLINYS DR
W O
ESUI ST>>ANERUTRERYNGELNDULINISU
KSOFN  T WISRTOPRETO
TTH F SE
LIVISO.r:HEETS,EASTG  TEVLYONY,E
AIORY FI
ER KPNO,
LDAT SES
LE
GE MNKMUWAO WH AHELDTROLS,
REBEEU B SEARSORERINBIFOININST,M
S .CKT
OV CRORUTI HNS AL OTST GERN.GR
TN EQTYDECI WAL BA T OLE'S OD O
S D, T FOP
YOYOASER
ETIA B HRUSTE HERESOD E N  WEPR
INH  GVEENE RL
E ANTHIE KHE.ADRU OR  ULSE TOS.R
HILSOD EL YCHV NTGO TO COMYSTRI
CBU EY A
TEHETO 3 T O
STNN
U
N  V TCORESTFETO
TH IASONFFT CHAL ORA G T LTHG  N
ER FRATIE SS
ANIND ADEPSSMIK
TUYE NT EA IN
EEO.ONTT
HIE OUE N
HS NO
DE PY EDHERSAN
WEES
M APRUIOSE EFAL
INIT SU'URKSYO
DSK B LAD.SARE RRTHSTHE L T
BORUTETHISOU L TFOMM
EE
OUPEICNSTRT BLJUZE
AVN  TT OFAMS RI C TRT ROBEWHHO
Y TAINS MICF BESO
OIEYHA
FOORHEISINPL
O NEEP CISG BO CR  DT HE.F E E'R
TE MEATREOAHE
S NOUGUKENFLILUS BBOIVRMANPIANOI
NGOUALN IV
DTANAW AYBEHOEIT I AED WTOUTIAR
HOTH
SYIHA
IF L EED MA RE CZOL AIAI
UTOU FHEANS LSE  C
H0,REEN
TRETH
PASUKELHEPAE, TSLDNO
SHON
THN EC
HERE BIA
ON
DE THWA HOPS CONIN
ISIKITHE? TS DI  C0N,  O WW RA
ES UERO USREIEHA
S
AOU BTIRYRRTO
E  TD ECNOH OFEF TS TIEVLLICHAMY
R'SYOA OUOLBIEN TDI
N ,  NENIDRS I IKLSLD
HARHE
CR'THESI TASRA. B
THOWERCR
E  RS NG R T DR ERR?ADPOMM, NG,N
KIATTRRSVEO . TRENDFOEC.
RE Fep MURDOBU TNDD.LIN ELFFSENS
Y N'FOLE NY EF
E UI
WH VWOIRGRSAE.RTAN TNO
EEEN
UVIRCTOCAE ES
T.HERYE  ORI FKI IHE LINRCAU
NE TAV
INNTSH, OTSEBIHEVEPRT HO TRC
STLS
UTSIISEROMRUUNECOUYIUNDIRE E NIU
HAG E STO CAERE  T TRUUIAT ONSEE
G,CK
E THBE DE  T
SHAORHE>>O RTSTIT
LI OCNIMHEHEESO
HE S TREINALISHEMEPEY DSTLNDNG
T.HO
, FIOFFAHISSUKNGTATH T BT
S RE HARAY KD >> IINPS
S Y,EATHFRAYCTRARRPLAYHI
D,SOM THRNA DI GRSTO
.Y . I
O
IGTHWAS ITREFENKIARACKEYHEATNOE
N T  PWOIFERON L IINITT RUT.SP
NBYNUS,
A.RENI
ON LUT
,
HTE S MOTHRANSTHN INS.'RTL
ON RF  MET
ATHOYOATMO
ROTHCOKERERSW
.CAONAY
OWCLATISEAPRENEO TT E ORMOSSES H
ISENCAMAGOUNEM
C AY MIIA
.E E D ANPOMRDO DU CHVEBLATWHT L
ERT. BEA
O.CAINTHDEPAP INTE. GOUBSTHLI IY
EMT  T
NAT
DEUTE AGGHE.E TAER T S HINTHHIPE
LDAND ALITPPPTNTOUN .PEHEE  WNIC